was your dad your major influence and
that did he play you records
because whenever i talk to recording
article there was tons of music in our
house
and like would your dad sit there and
play classic rock for you all the time
all the time all every single every
single night it was sort of a ritual
before and after dinner
he'd play uh pink floyd led zeppelin
bruce springsteen billy joel
and i used to just go daddy why is there
is there money sounds in that song and
he'd say well pink floyd wrote a song
called money and then he'd explain it to
me
so your father must sort of feel
somewhat responsible for your career
because he sat there with you and played
you queen which was where you got the
name gaga and all that stuff so he
probably feels good
and how long before you start to play
the piano yourself how old were you
i was four four years old yeah did you
take piano lessons
no not in the beginning what do you mean
you didn't take piano i mean at four you
would sit there and bang on the piano
and yet it made sense to you
well it made probably no sense but my
mom you know thought it was really sweet
and you know we had an upright piano in
the house and of all the toys that we
had
laying around i used to always just sort
of kneel on the floor and bang on the
keys
were you obsessed with the piano as a
kid yeah and i actually used to
uh like jerry lee lewis who stand on the
piano and i used to pretend to play but
i didn't you know it didn't really
sound very good and did you beg your
parents for lessons um i didn't at first
my mom just uh
got me lessons and actually my first
piano teacher was a stripper
yeah she was fabulous i used to ask
christ to say
i used to say why do you have such long
nails
for abuse piano and you tell me that
when i play piano my nails should be
very short so i can
have the proper position and she'd say
someday you'll understand why my nails
are long now do that
debussy again did you um like when you
were four years old did you start
writing music right away did you have
songs in your head um
yeah actually i tried to copy pink floyd
i wrote a song called money
that's that's a rip-off yeah they should
sue me immediately
what was the song do you remember it uh
no i i just notated it
um on my mother had bought me mickey
mouse staff paper
so i notated it um you know with the
real notes and it was so cute because it
was in the key of cheese
it was an f sharp you know it was really
sweet at four years old what do you
think what is your thought on money was
it that money was bad or money no i just
was confused as to why a rock and roll
band would put would put the sound of a
cash register in a song
you were obsessed with that i was up i
had i was like that's not rock and roll
daddy billy joel would never do that and
then he
explained to me that pink floyd uh
changed
the way that rock and roll was forever
was it hard for you to decide in your
career what type of music you'd play if
you were like kind of raised on like
hard rock and roll and pink floyd and
stuff like that
did you you you at some point became a
pop artist
and pop music and like a lot of dance
music yeah but was there a time you said
no no way i'm gonna do that i'm gonna
just be one of these rock guys like you
know i'm gonna be like pink floyd or i'm
gonna be
like billy joel or no cause i i think
that
all those influences uh they just
sort of gave birth to me in a way and
the artist that i've become is just
who i was always destined to be i you
know moved downtown when i was 19 and
uh there was a huge sort of
singer-songwriter rock
indie scene and to be honest i just
didn't want to be
another one of the chicks in the pack i
wanted to
for myself revolutionize what was
underground music in new york
so i made pop music there was a period
of time where you were a songwriter for
other people
yeah and the sort of the famous story is
that britney spears
which song did you write that you would
submit it to her and she turned it down
a couple
i did uh one for her that she used
called quicksand
right um and then i wrote telephone for
her
right and she didn't put it out on an
album no when you were writing for other
people
did it kill you inside because you
probably said these are really good
songs i should be doing
no freaking britney spears saying my
record are you kidding i was doing
backflips and ordering drinks
were you depressed early on because you
were assigned to a record label
i guess a record came out you were
signed to someone for like three or four
months i don't know who the hell it was
def jam def jam and when you signed with
them you probably said to yourself oh my
god it's finally coming true
this is my big break i'll break through
i'm on def jam it's a great label
everyone gets me did you think it was
over when
that whole deal didn't work out oh yeah
i mean well i
i was gonna keep going anyway but you
know more of the concern is
how do you make your daddy proud you
know how do you make an honest woman of
yourself
for your family and i was more concerned
with my parents not feeling like
i was you know leaving a legacy for
our family and i my parents you know
they didn't come from money and i didn't
come for money they were both
really hard-working uh but both in
uh you know the internet business and
communications they both were the first
to go to college
were you the embarrassment of the family
in the sense that like oh my god
she's pursuing this dream it's never
gonna happen i'm sure your parents were
worried about it not an embarrassment at
all i think it was more just confusing
because i was really
really smart in school and i think that
you know theater and academia and the
theater sense was
what they saw for my future um and i
just
started doing a lot of drugs and moved
downtown and started burlesque and
that could scare a parent if you
absolutely but if you hadn't made it
it would have been the worst thing in
the world because you probably felt such
pressure from your parents not that they
were doing it even it's just an internal
thing you were going through see that's
the thing though is i had already
felt like i had made it me living
in new york in an 1100 a month apartment
paying my own rent
doing my own shows dressing how i like
singing how i like doing my hair low i
like
i already felt like i had made it so i
only and always have
just wanted to make music and do it my
way